a year ago an earthquake and tsunami
triggered meltdowns at the Fukushima
Daiichi nuclear power plant in Japan
driving onto the site today the
aftermath is still easy to see cleanup
operations are in full swing thousands
of workers are removing debris and
building defenses to prevent the further
spread of radioactivity a cover over the
unit one reactor was completed in
October and workers have erected
barriers to try and prevent
radioactivity from flowing into the
Pacific Ocean plastic sheeting hung from
these orange boys is designed to catch
contaminated particles in December the
plant's owner TEPCO announced that all
three reactors had reached cold shutdown
that means the cores are no longer
boiling temperatures but it doesn't mean
fukushima's problems are solved the
reactors are full of holes and cooling
water leaks into buildings and basements
it must be pumped out filtered to remove
radiation and then recycled back into
the reactors and the insides of the
reactors are still very much mystery
workers can only venture so far before
high radiation levels make it too
dangerous robots can get closer
here we see one taking dust samples to
monitor the high levels of radioactivity
in January engineers managed to get a
tiny camera inside the unit to reactor
but they couldn't see much the colored
specks you see are caused by deadly
radiation from the core
beyond the plants boundary there are
problems too the government has
announced major cleanup operations to
begin in April but nobody knows where
the radioactive debris will go Japan
doesn't have a nuclear waste repository
over 100,000 residents of Fukushima
remain displaced as a result of the
accident there is measurable
radioactivity throughout much of the
evacuation zone and beyond in many areas
the levels are too low to pose a health
risk most evacuate could probably return
to their home soon but it remains to be
seen whether anyone will workers at the
planet must play a much longer game
until radioactive fuel inside the
reactors decays further they will have
to focus on maintaining cooling
strengthening the plant's defenses
against another quake and
decontamination here they're spraying a
suppressant to keep down radioactive
dust it will be years before anyone gets
a clear look inside the battered
reactors and it will be longer still
before they are removed for nature news
I'm Jeff Brohm feel
you